hello and welcome back to the rogue mm
as always my name is Caleb Denby and I
will be your driver on this journey
today I wanted to take a look at a
tournament that happened last year and
that tournament is the st. Louis rapid
and blitz it's pretty relevant that I'm
going over this tournament if you can
see behind me but it's about to happen
again coming up in just a few short days
the top ten players will all be here in
st. Louis all ready to compete in this
rapid and blitz event and some of you
might wonder is it worth looking at
these rapid games or these blitz games
you know because the chess is really
it's it's a different kind of chess at
that level and I honestly think
sometimes the rapid games at the top
level can be more instructive than the
classical games this is because in the
classical games you'll often see the
players do a ton of home preparation
make sure they really deeply understand
the positions and then play everything
out on the board the way they imagined
it and then maybe find some you know
insane ideas that are hard to replicate
at the class level but the rapid games
are more often very very fun very very
exciting and have a lot more mistakes
that probably we can relate to a little
bit more this first game I wanted to
look at was from the first day of the
tournament
it was between Fabiano Cara Juana and
shocked mom and Yara of Fabi actually
had an incredible start to the 2018
rapid a blitz
he won all three of his rounds on day
one unfortunately he didn't manage to
keep that up and ended up I think
placing fourth in the event but day one
was kind of a shocker for everybody to
see him come out and just destroy all of
his opponents so like I said his first
victim here was shocked Mahmud yarv and
let's take a look at how this game went
they started with a roy lopez the
classical line with night of six castles
and now the main moves that you might
have seen are b5 sometimes they play
Bishop e7 and then there's also this
move Knight takes e4
so are you guys kind of familiar with
the Roy a little bit have you seen this
line before so yeah it's a pretty common
line
you know black takes the spawn
momentarily but he's going to have some
problems because this file is now
opening and his King is still stuck in
the center the game continues with d4
further opening the file b5 d5 and now
white regains the pawn this should be
six night BT to Knight c5 c3 this should
be seven bishops e2 and d4 so so far
this is all kind of been theory but so
what do you guys think about this
position this is probably one you
haven't seen quite as much this is
pretty deep but so what do you what do
you think's going on here you should
rather be white or black
you'd rather be black why is that yeah
so this Bishop on c1 is a little bit
stuck blacks pieces are mostly developed
I think a big thing to take note of here
is these two pawns this is the big
imbalance in the position that's how I
feel at least so black has this powerful
deep on which he would like to push
further down the board but meanwhile
White has this powerful epon so you'll
kind of see the way this game goes is
who can prove which pawn is a weakness
first white would love to pile up on
this pawn the further advances but the
further it advances the less space white
will have for his pieces so let's see
how the players went about you know
solving this position so Knight to b3
and now d3 so black is really shoving
this pawn as far as he can put it this
should be one the night takes b3 it
takes b3 this pawn needs some defense
somehow so we see Bishop f5 and now b4
and let's see the black gets castled ch3
Queen d7 Bishop f4 Rick FD 8 now g4 so
believe it or not this is actually still
theory I believe both Fabiano and
shocked mom and Yara of have both had
this position before
which is pretty crazy that that they're
this far deep but yeah this is all still
home prep so we see Bishop g6 Bishop g3
and h5 so now we're kind of at the end
of their theory I believe so what's
going on here so once again we see this
pawn on d3 and the battle is really
about whether or not this pawn is an
advantage or a weakness whether or not
white can capture this pawn somehow or
if black can maintain this pawn and kind
of stifle the white pieces something
else that's really relevant going on in
the position is White has made this
expansion to kind of harass this Bishop
a little bit and maybe get some play on
the Kings side using this advanced fun
and black is now kind of striking back
these these kind of loose kind of weak
pawns because of that we saw in the game
Knight d2 adding some defense to this
pawn in the previous game that shock had
in this position he was playing black
against Anand and I believe that game
went rookie one and the game continued
with d2 rookie to take stakes and now we
see that white does capture this pawn
but in exchange for it black is getting
a pawn on the Kings side and so because
both players kind of got rid of their
weaknesses white got rid of his weakness
on the Kings side black got rid of his
central pawn weakness this game ended
pretty peacefully pretty quickly in a
draw they agreed to a draw I think here
so perhaps Bobby knew of this game it's
quite likely the that he did you know
you don't really go down this line
without understanding that your opponent
has played it before and having
something special prepared so he ones
Knight d2 so what do you think the
difference is between this move and move
that Anand played rook e1 is this move
somehow fighting for a win more more
than a non dead with Ricky one
what do you think
and the ideas
so how is 92 92 is fighting for a win
more than a non Dead with jerky won but
what what's the difference why is this
the case no ideas
so in chess mm-hmm
so yeah in chess the way chess games are
won especially at the top level but
really at any level is due to imbalances
you have some advantage in some weakness
your opponent has a different advantage
in a different weakness and it's kind of
a battle to see who can make the most
out of it so in the in this game
blacks you know whites weakness is kind
of on the Kings side blacks weakness is
kind of on d3 and so in the nons game we
saw after Ricky won both players get rid
of their weakness and if you're missing
these weaknesses then there's not too
much to play for it's kind of tough to
prove an advantage and this can be true
at all levels of chess so Fabi played 92
which is you know keeping this pawn
alive kind of defending it but it's also
keeping the black pawn alive so this
means both players will still have to
contend with their weakness for a little
bit longer in this game so there's a
little bit more to play for here black
dick captured and now let's see so this
is a really really interesting position
given a couple of moves a couple of free
moves let's say black just passes what
do you think white would like to be
doing here in the hint I'll give you is
that this is really his big spatial
advantage he wants to make use of this
pawn somehow
so it's important to try to be able to
come up with ideas even in positions
that you're not totally familiar with so
let's think how can white try to either
gain more space activate his pieces or
kind of harass blacks pieces can we do
any of these things
some people in YouTube have some
interesting ideas do you guys have any
any idea
so okay this is an interesting idea okay
so you're trying to make use of your
kind of dark square advantage here by
bringing this knight in that is an
interesting idea but actually in this
case I think I'm gonna have to go with
the YouTube chat on this one I think
what white wants to do is play f4
supporting this pawn now that the knight
is out of the way this pawn is free to
move and given another turn black's
bishop is really going to be shut out
and this would be kind of devastating
for the black site here once this bishop
is set up shut out its interference with
this diagonal well it's interfering with
by this pawn so it can't really defend
this pawn very very well which means
that white is probably going to be able
to come and pick this upon up quite
easily so you kind of see White's trying
to use his advantage to play against
Blacks weakness even in this indirect
manner with that of Mines
Black's position is actually kind of
tough to play how do you come up with a
move for black here because you need to
do something pretty quickly or else this
idea is just going to you know kind of
be shoved down your throat and there's
not much you can do about it one common
idea might be a5 and then if white were
to try to continue this maybe you can
take this pawn over here but the fact of
the matter is I'm not so sure this is
really something you want to go down
anyways you haven't really stopped f4 f5
so because of that black got very very
creative here very creative so what's
the if you guys can find the solution
that shot came up with to play even
faster than a 5 he needs very quick play
in order to prevent this f4 f5
this one's pretty crazy it's what made
this game so interesting
so I'll give you a little bit of a hint
black would love to use this pawn to
support his other pawn obviously
something is wrong with that there's a
knight in the way so what do you think
any ideas any sacrifices that you might
be able to find so you could take on e5
but this sacrifice actually kind of
opens up White's they should be even
further this isn't really what we want
to go for and after something like c5
the white pawn is actually ready to
recapture and this pawn continues
continues to be weak
yeah so actually it is night takes
before this is the move that Shaq came
up with and this move is a much better
try because if white recaptures black
can recapture and now the path is
completely clear for this pondo kind of
come and support its its friend over
here and this f4 f5 plan is going to be
a lot less powerful now for example if F
forward were to be played I'll just try
and figure out what could be done here
it looks like we could probably use our
new piece activity to actually just win
this G pond so we really are just
directly preventing f4 f5 with this idea
at the cost the not so low cost of a
knight so this is the type of
interesting chess that you don't really
see in a classical game at the top level
and the reason for that is when you get
to imbalances that are kind of this
severe this kind of you know ridiculous
unbalanced kind of positions generally
it favors one side generally one side is
favored over the other and so they don't
want to play this in classical when
everybody has time to work out what's
going on because then you know this side
that's winning will win and the side
that's losing shouldn't have gone for it
however in a rapid game they're much
more likely to go for something like
this because it's interesting there's no
way they're going to play it accurately
and both sides will have a lot of
chances with that of Mines let's see the
next move we saw a bishop a - so what do
you think is going on here which side
which side do you prefer the white side
with the piece or the black side with
the pawns you'd rather have the extra
night that's fair
that's fair
yes so this is what White's last move
was aiming for actually is trying to
break open the kingside with a six try
and do again find counterplay using his
advantage
this extra night is pretty useful in
helping to stop these puns but if white
just sits back and does nothing this
eventually
this will come down the board and then
white will have a lot to answer for
so if you prefer the white pieces I
think you have to understand that you
really do have to create counterplay you
have to be quick in your play here you
can't really just sit back on your extra
material and kind of assume that you
will eventually win the game because in
reality I think it is it's black who
will eventually win if white doesn't do
something because black has this very
clear plan let's say you know why it
plays some nothing moves any like Rick
see one all of a sudden you can see
these these pawns have made some pretty
serious advances into the position and
if we're not careful this Bishop might
move and then this pawn and this pawn
might come and really a the end of the
game could approach pretty soon
so after c5 Bobby realized that he
needed to play pretty quickly he played
a six really drew trying to break things
open as quickly as possible
black of course captures and now we see
Knight f3 bringing the knight into some
weaknesses that uh this pawn push
created C 495 Queen e8 let me see King G
2 which is kind of a strange move the
idea I think is that Fabia wants to be
able to use use this h-file if necessary
as well as maybe you can block off this
diagonal with f3 if he needs rook d5
trying to double the rooks f3 Rick 88
Rick h1 now you might notice that these
are actually not the greatest moves
being played but that's of course
because this position is just so absurd
that it's it's kind of tough to find the
best moves so what you'll see these top
players doing is just like you know
lower rate of players when they don't
know what to do they kind of fall back
on principles in this case Bobby found a
square for his Knight and now he's just
trying to improve his pieces and start
an attack meanwhile shock is just
putting his rooks on
you know the most important file
preparing to push these pawns and make
sure all those pieces stay connected
Bishop d6 Queen e1 and now d2 so shock
finally finally pushes forward C Queen
III Bishop c2 really trying to push this
guy home say rook a d1 and then Bishop
takes d1 so actually believe it or not
Bishop takes d1 was one of shocks
biggest mistakes in this game there's a
saying in chess at least I think it's a
saying
where if the piece isn't going to be
able to move anywhere then you shouldn't
really waste your time capturing it
right away this shows up but that's not
a real saying but you know you get the
idea
this shows up in a lot of different
positions you'll see that you know you
should really never be capturing a
pinned piece right because if you
capture a pinned piece then it's no
longer pins you know it can't move
anywhere anyways because it's pinned so
why would you waste your time capturing
it the same idea kind of works here this
rook isn't going to be able to move
anywhere because black will be able to
Queen so black really shouldn't waste
his time capturing it right now there
are plenty of other good moves to make
such as takes in Queen d7 kind of just
sitting on the position and once again
he can eventually fall back on on this
plan of pushing these pawns forward
there's no rush to really capture this
rook in the game though he did capture
white captured back takes takes and now
rook d3 and this was a pretty nonchalant
move from shock meaning meaning he
didn't really understand that the
consequences of this move so you might
have noticed that White has been hinting
at this Kings side for a while now and
rook d3 actually helps launch this
attack for whites so how does riff d3
help White's attack
Queen where yes Oh Queen g5 is one
option
black might be able to defend with Queen
d7 maybe Queen f7
well this rook defends hopefully let's
say a queen Queen d7
I'm not so sure that this this attack it
is really really getting the job done
one thing to keep in mind is you always
want to be on the lookout for how you
can bring more pieces in V attack so
just this Bishop in this queen really
aren't going to be able to get it done
we need another helper the Queen g5 is
the most forcing so it's good to look at
it because it threatens checkmate but
there's actually a better square for
this Queen
I'll give you a hint everybody in the
room I guarantee has been checkmated in
this way before
yeah what do you think it each it Queen
on g5 so that's what we've been looking
at so it threatens checkmate but I think
black might just be able to defense one
of many many ways and then there's no
way to really continue the attack
immediately so there's a better square
for this Queen than g5 Queen a7 I think
this one isn't it yeah so you do get to
capture this pawn but I'm not sure this
pawn is the most relevant we want to be
looking at this King's side yes Queenie
for it that's the move I was looking for
it
so my vague hints might have not helped
so much but the piece I was hoping you
would bring into the attack is actually
this bishop it's bishops kind of stunted
looking at this this Rock of a pawn on
c4 so we'd love to get it on this
diagonal where as we've all seen before
the Queen could come into h7 and deliver
some some checkmating patterns so e4 is
actually the best place for this Queen
and now I think white is actually simply
winning we see rook eight to d5 but now
after Bishop d3 this rook really can't
move anywhere if you move out of the way
it's a simple checkmate - so now at this
point black is actually forced to give
back one of his rooks for a bishop and
then white will simply be up a full
piece so we see Queen f7 and now white
captures the material takes takes and
after Queen 88 and a trade white is
simply winning the son game the reason
for that is because bishops are really
good and pawns aren't quite as good
you might count and say that okay black
has three pawns for the piece so maybe
black will have you know drawing chances
but the fact is the pawns are really
only good if they can move anywhere and
after the simple move Bishop c3 it's
really tough to move any of these guys
ever again you see King g7 and
eventually what captures this pawn
and in the straight Bishop and King
versus King and game Fabi was just a
little bit faster and pawn takes c3 is a
nice finesse here so of course if black
were to queen fans of searching for
Bobby Fischer will have seen this type
of thing before
there's an unfortunate skewer at the end
so black is simply losing so black just
resigned after B takes c3 so that was a
really crazy game right so what can we
take away from this game I get I guess
is the point I'm trying to make and that
point can really be broken down to into
a few a few mistakes in the game that
really plague players of all levels so
we saw you know both players playing
natural moves some mistakes were being
made but you know the moves are still
natural they're just improving their
pieces and we saw here kind of shocks
first mistake he is capturing a piece
that can't go anywhere so he's kind of
wasting his time allowing white to
regroup his pieces more effectively much
better is to play a move like Bishop to
c7 just defending this pawn or Bishop
takes e5 when white wouldn't be able to
regroup quite so quite so effectively
because he doesn't have this information
yet he's not able to react to this
bishop threat so that's a big mistake
don't take pieces that uh that can't run
away and then the next big mistake I
think is is really more important it's
very intuitive it's very natural to try
to kick your pieces away but it's
useless to do this if you're kicking
your opponent's pieces into better
squares and I see this all the time in
games of all levels you want to make a
one move threat against a Queen to make
it move somewhere else but in fact
you're actually only improving the Queen
and it was that case here black forces
the Queen to move on to a better Square
where now white can bring more attackers
into the game
and black is simply losing already
thanks to these slight inaccuracies any
questions about this game I know this
game is really difficult to understand
hopefully did a reasonable job trying to
unpack it the main points I wanted you
to take away were this don't take pieces
that can't run away and then don't push
your opponent's pieces onto better
squares any questions though why I
didn't white want to play b3
I'm sorry what what position are you
Oh
mm-hmm
so b3 is actually a pretty common idea
against a structure like this the
problem here is that if b3 and black can
actually simply advance further
and unless white was able to stop this
advance from being good then b3 is never
really going to work because once these
two pawns get this far up the board and
are connected like this it's really
difficult to stop them
if you imagine some position like I
don't know say say black/white got a few
free moves in a position like this b3
would actually be really interesting and
I think it would be a great move because
now of course c3 is impossible so it's
definitely one idea that white could
have played for it just wasn't what he
went for in the game probably because he
didn't think II had enough time to
achieve it so yet on all these turns
if b3 is played c3 would have been the
response but yeah B throughs interesting
idea to look out for any other questions
all right well let's move on to game
number two then so we showed one of
fabi's you know incredible wins from the
first day now we're going to show one of
his unfortunate losses from the rest of
the tournament
this was his game against Lenny a
Dominguez and I wanted to go over this
one for a couple of reasons one reason
is I think it's the funniest game of the
tournament or the most heartbreaking
depending on who you are but this game
was actually in one of kramnik favorite
lines where after C takes on d5 we don't
take back with the pawn which is kind of
it's the normal way to play but instead
we take back with the knight and so this
line gives white a big center after E
for takes takes you you see you know why
it has good central control but black is
going to try to break down the center
pretty quickly see c5 Knight f3 takes
takes bishop check Bishop d2 takes takes
castles
and now already Fabiano went a little
bit a little bit insane so what are some
normal moves you might expect white to
play here yeah you know Bishop b2 Bishop
c4 maybe you might get this rook to an
open file you might replay those three
moves maybe something else maybe bring
the Queen somewhere maybe you improve
your knight
but what Bobby did was actually a
novelty I don't think it had ever really
been played before at the top level here
he played h4 so this is the type of
stuff that makes rapid games so fun is
the top players start playing like like
a hustler in the park you know what I
mean they just launched down an H pawn
and then they start some random attack
on the Kings side that should never work
but uh it somehow seems to work out
sometimes with not so much time on the
clock so Bobby plays h4 Dominguez
develops his pieces
Bobby plays h5 bunny a it decided that
was far enough you played h6
stopping the white punt and of course
Bobby falls it up with g4 so what do you
think is going on here do you think that
this is something that makes sense for
white to be doing expending on the Kings
side or do you think he's weakening too
many squares for it to be good
yeah that's a great point moving this G
pawn forward really weakens this
diagonal and so that's something White's
going to have to look out for with that
ax mines are that there are advantages
to pushing on the Kings side right so
what are some of those advantages for
white
what might he be planning in the next
few moves
yeah there's this push up to g5 this is
really what black is going to have to
deal with for the game and this is the
common idea to look out for in
structures like this this is a
structural you'll you'll kind of see
quite often actually in the karo you'll
kind of get it but the bishop might be
on age seven or traded off for this
bishop in this case it's a little bit
different because these two bishops are
on the board
so maybe the white bishop can kind of
help out attack on the Kings side
so what White's saying is that it's
worth all these squares he's weakening
because his attack on the Kings side is
going to be fast enough to make up for
it in the game Bishop d7 was played and
queen e3 defending this diagonal from
this pawn knight c6 a3 kind of a
strange-looking move but an important
one to stop this knight from coming in
to b4 we see b5 this should be to a6 d1
so white has kind of pushed all these
pawns on the Kings side now he's playing
a bit more slowly but these are all just
natural moves blocking this Knight from
getting into the game supporting the
center and preparing to push either g5
or d5 in the coming moves Queen a5 check
the the White King finds a home on f1
and now black finally decides to do
something about this g5 pushed by
playing f6 favi continues to support it
with York to g1 black plays Knight to e7
kind of opening up this diagonal and now
Fabi decides to play d5 so this is
something I wanted to talk about over
the past few moves we've seen Fabi
actually play it a little bit more
slowly my arrow keys stopped working
it's devastating so we saw him push this
h5 in g4
but then after that he played some
preparatory moves he actually just
developed his pieces and played Rick to
d1
so what I wanted to mention is that even
when you are creating weaknesses like
this it's very important not to open up
the position until you're absolutely
ready for it rushing your plan is
something I think a lot of players kind
of struggle with so Fabi really puts all
of his pieces on the best square before
he breaks through and opens the center
he's even put his King on what might be
the best square on the board for it it's
not a great square but f1 is I think
about as safe as this King is going to
get so when you're you know getting
ready to open up the position like this
you really want to make sure your pieces
are placed in the best places that could
be now you do have to balance this with
making sure that you don't give your
opponent too much time to prepare for it
but in general you really want to
prepare to open up the position before
you just kind of go out and do it but
that of Mines Fabi decided this was the
right moment he played d5 and after
takes
he plays takes and after Knight takes
there's this Queen e6 tactic and here
Fabi does not actually take this simply
because he decided this rook was worth
more than these two pieces I believe
once again this is kind of a crazy
position Knight h4 also creates a threat
on the king and the rook so these are
just you know tactical lines we see
Knight f4 hitting the Queen Queen e7
Queen c3 and so this was actually I
think the big mistake in the game so
once again this is something you have to
look out for in these rapid games these
players are playing such complex
positions that neither of them really
have time to figure out what's going on
so there's a lot of back-and-forth I
think best might just be to save this
Bishop believe it or not just take the
time out of your day to play a move like
Bishop c6 save the bishop from capture
instead this Queen c3 move and it
doesn't really make as much sense what
he was going for was after it takes he
wanted to get some activity on the Kings
side but in the end it's really not
worth the full piece let me simply see
Knight G to blocking the check takes on
a to take
to check Queen f3 and white has just
enough pieces to kind of stop all the
checks this Knight can come back to III
at some point and open the lines and why
this is simply winning here so how did
white manage that from this crazy
position so this is something I wanted
to talk about a little bit is when the
position kind of gets crazier than
either player can calculate you tend to
just want to play simple chess chess
that makes sense to you chess that is
kind of principled obviously there's a
lot more going on in the minds of like
lenio Dominguez and Fabia Cara Juana
then just trying to play moves that you
know follow chess principles but in
general this is what's best to fall back
on your opponent attacked your piece
move your piece out of the way you know
it can be that simple sometimes
obviously there's a lot to calculate in
a lot going on but especially in this
rapid time control when you can't
calculate everything or if you're low on
time you want to play simple chests
chest that makes sense
chest that you know defends your pieces
and so I think that was Lenny his big
mistake here is he went for some
complicated line that he didn't really
have time to figure out and in the end
he kind of got burns because white
simply takes the piece and then defends
his King black followed this up with
your up d8 going for this imbalance with
two rooks and a night for the Queen of
course this should favor Fabi but here
comes the the heartbreaking part of the
game or the funny part of the game
depending on who you are Fabia maneuvers
the rook arounds a lot of this is just
time pressure trying to get the pieces
situated I did want to mention here that
a black actually had an opportunity to
get his way back into this game so what
do you think black could have tried to
to make this game interesting again
so not really these pawns aren't gonna
be super relevant one thing about Queens
is that they are great at creating
threats but usually to create like
checkmating threats they kind of need
some help and that help can come from
really any other piece and in this case
I think the help might come from upon
this might be might be the best way to
achieve it so how can we bring in more
attackers to create more distinct
threats against the white king so g5 is
interesting it might be a little bit too
weakening of your own king though let's
maybe just maybe not this check but yeah
it just it weakens a lot of squares I'm
not entirely sure of of the best way to
refute it
let's try simply playing like Nike for
maybe I'll give this movie shots
there's some checks I'll run this way
all I'm trying to say is that you're
weakening a lot of squares and I might
be doing something like this soon
um in fact maybe your h1 is is the
proper way to take advantage of this
this is something slightly less
weakening to bring in more attackers on
the way it King
so yeah Nicholas Olsen in the YouTube
chat actually has the answer the movie I
was looking for was f5 and the point is
later in the game fi was played but
white had the option to respond with f4
obviously that one doesn't really work
here because it leaves the knight behind
so yet no matter what white does we're
probably going to play a four next turn
and now all of a sudden the White King
has has a lot of lot of problems
especially with this pawn here to kind
of help out probably what black has to
do is try to find counter play with
something like rook to b7
but now this King is actually awkwardly
placed you can't really go to g2 thanks
to this check when a black would pick up
the Queen and if you go back to e2 I
think this might be a perpetual if you
know black doesn't actually find
something more here well let's see
there's actually this move to worry
about hmm
okay maybe I'm miss playing something
let's see what do we think what do we
think
Queens c1 King e2 and the rook is
hanging I knew I was missing something
okay well done everyone who spotted that
okay so a black should have played f5
here it technically works and it brings
in more attackers to the white king
obviously it's a rapid game you're not
going to see every tactic so I think
like simply missed this one so Queen c7
and the game continued with Rick f8
Queen e7 they continued to maneuver the
pieces somehow someway black picked the
wrong square one time so now we see f5
and white does respond with f4 keeping
this pawn away from the Kings so black
can't generate as many threats Queen d4
King e2 Queen takes f4 the route comes
up to c5 we an H 2 you check right G 2
and then eventually black slips up a
little bit and let's wait to bring this
rook into the attack on the black King
h5 happens we see takes takes check
check check check check
and then after King e2 queenie for I'll
bet none of you can guess so Fabiana
carolina lost this game can any of you
guess how Fabi Cara wanna the game ends
after the next move the game's over he
resigns and shame and storms out of the
tournament Hall rook h8 that's a good
guess it's not quite rotated shape
though you're on the right track you're
on the right track
rook g6 well white wouldn't have to
resign after your Chi 6 I'll give you a
hint
he thought he was going to play Knight
takes f5 winning the game he played
rookie 7
black captured the game ended Fabi was
under the impression he was going to
play Knight takes f5 check forcing the
King to h7 and recapturing the Queen
however this did not come to fruition so
I wanted to include this game because
one-one it was is you know they had the
funniest ending there was also some
stuff to learn from it most of this game
of course was just kind of craziness
where both players are just doing the
best that they can
once again my only advice for those
types of positions but you're gonna find
yourselves in from time to time is just
fall back on principles simple chests
things that you understand and try to
use those to guide you through the super
complicated positions it won't work in
every position but at least keep you
from mistakes like the one Lenny I made
here where he simply gives up this
Bishop for some mysterious counterplay
that wasn't really worth in the end of
course try to avoid playing ricky 7
blundering a rook misunderstanding
ho-how pins work in chess so yeah this
one this was a really I think the
turning point for fabi's tournament
because you know he won his first three
games going into the rapid and then all
of a sudden you know he plays this game
he's kind of out of contention out of
contention with the remaining time I did
want to look at it a game of the winner
Hikaru Nakamura he is the person who
managed to win the 2018 st. Louis rapid
and blitz and this is the game that
really clinched it for him he had black
and shocked Mahmoud yarv who was his
closest follower I believe at this point
and he managed to win this game putting
him in clear first
and I think securing the win I don't
know if he actually clinched it in this
round but let's take a look 9 f3 Knight
of 6 c4 e6 III d5 b3 this should be 7
Bishop b2 and then kind of the Shocker
move so who is familiar with this
position have you seen anything like
this before
yeah so the other caleb is familiar with
this something you'll often see here is
something like c5 and eventually the
knight c6 castles castles maybe I'm
misremembering a little bit but
eventually you get some position yeah
this bishop doesn't go to e2 but okay
something like this castles castles d4
takes takes rook e1 and you get this
this style of structure with the reverse
Benoni so this is really what is kind of
the only way the black plays in this
position is they go for this structure
with the reverse benoni and they play
this position however black did
something crazy in this game and he took
on c4 so this is something that had
really never been played before and has
really not been played since and that's
the type of stuff you'll find in these
rapid tournaments they just want to play
chess sometimes so he takes on c4 white
takes on c4 and really this just kind of
violates some principles it gives away
the center pawn for a be pawn and
White's going to have a stronger center
now and good squares for his pieces we
see c5 trying to battle for the d4
square Knight c3 g6 g4 so Oh white tries
to launch an attack on the Kings side
Bishop d7 g5 Knight the FD 7h 4 and so
this is becoming kind of a theme where
the the white player pushes all his
pawns on the Kings side 95 and white
actually capture this captures this
sacrificing in exchange but after Queen
a 497 and f3 maybe this Bishop is
trapped
so here we see b5 an interesting move
trying to unpin this Queen we actually
see Knight takes b5 rather than queen
after 95 white actually makes a mistake
here so what do you guys think is the
best move
what is the best move
there's some tempting options here
yes the 96 is maybe playable the problem
is after the king moves your Knights
going to be hanging and it's a little
tough to fix
Bishop takes e5 was suggested and this
was that what was actually played in the
game but I think here black and just
castle as was playing in it in the game
yeah so I think the best move here is
actually just 97 forcing this King to f8
kind of miss placing the black king
before recapturing here there's probably
a variety of reasons why white kind of
shied away from this one maybe being he
thought this night would be a little
misplace be a little misplaced on on c7
perhaps I don't know how black might
respond here maybe something like rook
c8 and then the flight Queen takes a 7
this Bishop gets started gets to free
itself and black is technically up one
exchange here but you know White has a
nice a pawn and whites pieces aren't
really horribly placed however in the
game
like I said white didn't go for this
just play Bishop takes e5 falling back
you know on simple moves black castles
we see Bishop e2 trying to maintain the
trap of this Bishop f6 simply castles
daring black to take kind of a ruining
his pawn structure in exchange for
getting the Bishop back we see Bishop g2
rook g1 Bishop h3 just extracting this
Bishop it's Bishop drops back to a 1 and
now e5 so this move is actually mistake
why do you think this this move is is
something that wasn't actually quite
accurate it's a little tough to kind of
see straight away it's actually not so
much the d5 square because blacks plan
is simple he's gonna drop this Bishop
back control d5 an attack c4
so what's wrong with a 5 the answer is
really what's wrong with with most pawn
moves and it's that it leaves weaknesses
behind but what weaknesses in particular
do we care about
so you're saying this d5 square you're
saying II five maybe white can play E
for and after the bishop comes here you
want to drop this Bishop back and come
to d5 so that is an interesting idea I
don't think that's what is actually the
problem here I think after after this
this Knight lands on d5 I think black
might be happy to capture it I don't
know how you would like to recapture
here maybe like this but all of a sudden
black might find some counter place
somehow by opening up some some lines
some uncomfortable play it's a little
more straightforward than then using
this d5 square
maybe you've less I don't know Wow so f4
is interesting I think the problem with
f4 is that black can respond by a by
defending some important squares so the
squares this move leaves behind what
squares in particular we've noticed the
d5 square there's also the f5 Square and
in particular this entire diagonal is
weakened by this move of a 5 and for
that reason that's why this move is
really wrong
so what white can do to take advantage
of it is to place this piece on this
diagonal I gave the answer way cuz in
response to f4 I think what black might
play is this move Bishop f5 kind of
rendering this this disadvantage useless
so white really needs to you know take
this this diagonal as soon as you can
that's why I think Queen c2 was the best
move here and you know if black plays
naturally we can continue with Bishop d3
and we are really highlighting some
weaknesses in the black camp right now
you can't really play something like f5
because I can take this pawn here so
white kind of missed this opportunity in
the game but this is something to take
note of in your games is whenever you
move up on like this
this is mistakes that you know everybody
makes but you see them in these rapid
games because the grandmasters don't
have quite so willing to think about it
you really have to look at all the
squares it leaves behind and see if your
opponent or you know you if your
opponent makes a move
has any way to kind of exploit it to try
and really highlight those weaknesses in
this case this comes about through Queen
c2 taking away this square from the
bishop and you know putting some
pressure on this diagonal in the game
mama dear I've did not see this
he played Knight c3 instead perhaps
aiming for this d5 square like you guys
were talking about which also makes
sense we see Bishop e6 Queen c6 Queen
see it and now Knight d5 a tricky move
of course after takes there's this fork
so we see Bishop d8 instead Queen takes
rook takes takes Bishop takes Knight
takes Bishop takes and we find ourselves
in an endgame so which side do you
prefer in this endgame black or white
material count is technically even black
has a rook for the dark squared Bishop
and two pawns you prefer whites
mmm-hmm does anybody prefer black
yes the white is down the exchange but
he has two ponds for it you still go
with white
does anybody have any opinion on any
chest position
all right raise your hand if you like
black Caleb likes black you like black
raise your hand if you like white Caleb
likes white awesome so I think white is
really actually quite close to winning
here what the reason for that what is
the reason for that well the reason for
that is the rooks don't really have any
way to activate themselves to become
useful in order to be useful black needs
open files he needs ways to invade with
his rooks and he's kind of missing that
here there is this one open file on the
board but unfortunately for him a lot of
those squares are already controlled you
know stuff to get this rook on the file
thanks to this bishop and the B 2 square
is also defended and this bishop might
come to d3 and into c2 or maybe this
other route and block off this file
quite easily yet f3 is another
reasonable square it's important to note
that we can't leave this pond behind
should have mentioned that but the other
reason is it's not impossible to get
these pawns rolling for white these
pawns are actually slightly mobile you
can kind of imagine them going you can't
obviously play d4 straight away because
there's too much pressure on the c4 pawn
but you can imagine these pawns getting
going pretty quickly and finally there's
some pressure on the black King site
that you like really has to kind of
worry about where's the white King is a
bit safer so overall I would prefer
white in the Sun game because of you
know all those reasons so you see rooks
e6 probably aiming to get on the soap
and file King b2 kind of a strange move
but not necessarily bad and this rook
pokes this pawn on D to C this ship c3
Bishop f5 so now you know black is
trying to eye some squares on this B
file all of these moves are really
designed to find some way for the
further works to get into the game we
see h5 trying to highlight the weakness
on the black King but maybe this move
was a little bit too slow because now
these rooks actually do become
slightly active on this beef file CH 683
in this other rook slides over to b7 and
so black has achieved what he needs to
achieve really if you ever find yourself
with the extra exchange and in in an
endgame you just have to find some way
to activate your rooks to get them into
the position and that's a look like
achieved we see rook g1 Ricky 6 Bishop
e5 rook over so white is now really just
desperately trying to keep the black Rex
out black is passing with some time and
now eventually we see that the rook does
invade this trick comes up to g6
or okay one d4 so white gets these pawns
rolling rook a to check King g3 and now
this is actually where white lost the
game so you can't actually go King d3
leaving this bishop behind because after
2 c1 where does this bishop actually go
is a very important question if you try
to come to d2 let's see there's there's
some problem with it
I assume this is the problem and now no
matter what do you play if you go here
the bishop hangs if you go here the
bishop hangs if you go here and the
bishop hangs so why is simply losing a
piece here Richey one was a nice try to
defend it but after these nice moves the
bishop is once again pinned with nowhere
to go and here actually shocked resigned
to the game thereby essentially naming
Nakamura the 2018 wrap in a blitz
champion so this is kind of the game
that decided it for him so these were
three really insane games but the
hopefully the points I wanted you to
take away our first and foremost when
you get yourself into an insane
complicated position the best thing you
can do is fall back on simple principles
that you understand things that you
things that you know things that you can
calculate things like when your piece is
attacked move the piece out of the way
this is kind of the best way to avoid
falling into traps like the one that
leni a dominguez fell into in his game
against Carolina where he left his
bishop hanging in order to define some
counter play with some checks but then
it turns out his counter play kind of
fizzled out and he was just down a piece
in addition to that when you're trying
to play for a win you really want to
keep imbalances on the board you don't
want to be trading off your weaknesses
for your opponent's because in the end
if there are no weaknesses left there's
really nothing to play for and lastly in
this game we talked a little bit about
the endgame here pointing out that when
you have an extra exchange in the
endgame it's important to find open
files ways for the rooks to get active
that's really the way to try and prove
that the rook is worth more
any questions about any in the games
today or anything I covered overall no
questions you guys understand everything
about chests now these skins made total
sense well excellent well thank you all
for joining me this has been the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Denby
thank you all for joining
[Music]
you
[Music]